Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is, therestishistory.com. This episode is brought to you by HelloFresh. Be honest, between meetings, workout classes, and the kids' clubs, who's got time to cook? That's where HelloFresh comes in. No matter how busy you get, HelloFresh makes it easy to get a home-cooked meal on the table. With flavor-packed recipes like crispy chicken parmigiana,
感谢收听《一切皆历史》。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。再说一次，网址是 therestishistory.com。本集由 HelloFresh 赞助播出。说实话，在会议、健身课程和孩子们的俱乐部之间，谁有时间做饭？这就是 HelloFresh 发挥作用的时候。无论你有多忙，HelloFresh 都能让你轻松在餐桌上享用家常菜。凭借香气扑鼻的食谱，比如香脆帕尔马鸡排，
you'll be filling your kitchen with the cozy aromas of a homemade meal in no time. Visit HelloFresh.ca and use code SPOTIFY for your exclusive offer. Not sure what to get the young people on your list? Visit Fresh.ca and use code Spotify for your exclusive offer. Not sure what to get the young people on your list? The latest phone? Sneakers? Video games? Get the one thing they need now more than ever. Give their feelings a place to go.
你可以在短时间内让厨房充满自制饭菜的舒适香气。访问 HelloFresh.ca 并使用代码 SPOTIFY 获取您的独家优惠。不知道该给名单上的年轻人买什么？访问 Fresh.ca 并使用代码 Spotify 获取您的独家优惠。不知道该给名单上的年轻人买什么？最新的手机？运动鞋？电子游戏？买一件他们现在比以往任何时候都更需要的东西。给他们的情绪一个释放的去处。
When you donate to Kids Help Phone, you're giving the young people in your life and across the country access to free 24-7 judgment-free support. Because at the end of the day, it's their thoughts that count. Donate at KidsHelpPhone.ca. And together, we can give their feelings a place to go. Holiday shopping is never easy. An ugly holiday sweater. How did you know?
当你向青少年求助热线（Kids Help Phone）捐款时，你正在为生活在身边的以及全国各地的年轻人提供全天候免费、不带偏见的援助。因为归根结底，他们的想法才最重要。请在 KidsHelpPhone.ca 捐款。我们齐心协力，就能给他们的情绪一个释放的去处。节日购物从来都不容易。一件丑陋的节日毛衣。你怎么知道的？
Should have been a holiday scratch and win. Yes. Holiday scratch and win tickets available in stores now. Must be 19 plus to play. Scratch and win. Yes! Holiday Scratch and Win Tickets. Available in stores now. Must be 19 plus to play. Scratch and Win Tickets are not for kids. Charles the Prince, girded boldly with gleaming arms, tamed this people through numerous blows and a thousand triumphs.
本该买张节日刮刮乐。是的。节日刮刮乐门票现已在各大商店发售。必须年满 19 岁方可参与。刮刮乐。太棒了！节日刮刮乐门票现已在各大商店发售。必须年满 19 岁方可参与。节日刮刮乐门票不适合儿童。查理，这位王子，身披熠熠生辉的铠甲，英勇无畏，通过无数次的打击和千百次胜利驯服了这个民族。
He crushed it down and subjected it to himself with brandished sword. He dragged the battalions of those who in the depths of forests worshipped stock and stone into heavenly kingdoms. Afterwards, he poured over with the salvation bringing Jew of baptism the Untaught Saxons and sent them to the stars of heaven and led the new children of Christ into his hall. So that was a fellow called Paulinus. He was a scholar from Northern Italy. Lovely poem. I think it's a banger.
他以挥舞的长剑将其粉碎并纳为己有。他将那些在森林深处崇拜木石的军团拉入天国。随后，他将带有救赎之意的洗礼圣水倾注在无知的萨克逊人身上，将他们送往天上的繁星，并将基督的新信徒引领至他的殿堂。所以，这个人名叫保利努斯。他是来自意大利北部的学者。一首美妙的诗。我认为这是一首神曲。
And Paulinus, not just a bishop, but a saint, Tom. He becomes one in due course, not when he's written that poem, to be fair, but it's all in the future. Exactly. You get your sainthood partly as a reward for that beautiful poem. Yes, like the poet laureate. So he writes this poem in the year 777 and we are in the realm of Charlemagne, Charles the Great, Warlord of the West, great king, great emperor, as we will discover as this story continues. So Tom, give us a little bit of context. Charlemagne has been joint king of the Frankish Empire for nine years with his brother, Charlemagne. But a terrible thing has happened to Charlemagne. Charlemagne had a nosebleed,
而且保利努斯不仅是一位主教，还是一位圣人，汤姆。他最终会成为圣人，当然不是在他写下这首诗的时候，但那是未来的事。没错。你获得圣徒身份，部分是对那首美丽诗篇的奖赏。是的，就像桂冠诗人一样。所以他在公元 777 年写下了这首诗，我们正处于查理曼（查理大帝）的统治领域，他是西方的军阀、伟大的国王、伟大的帝王，正如我们在故事继续发展时所发现的那样。所以，汤姆，给我们简单介绍一下背景。查理曼与其兄弟卡洛曼共同担任法兰克帝国国王已有九年。但卡洛曼发生了一件可怕的事情。卡洛曼流鼻血了，
as listeners will remember, and has died. So Charlemagne is the last man standing. He is. So give us a little bit of context. We're in the aftermath of the Roman Empire. Yeah. So Charles, he rules the Franks. He's the son of Pepin, who's made himself king, getting rid of the Merovingian kings. He's the grandson of Charles Martel, great warlord. And Charles in Latin is Carolus. And so the dynasty that Pepin has founded and that Charlemagne belongs to is known by historians as the Carolingian dynasty. So Charles is top Carolingian, he's top Frank. And to be honest, he's top guy in Europe because
正如听众们所记得的那样，他已经去世了。所以查理曼是最后站着的人。他的确是。所以给我们一点背景。我们正处于罗马帝国瓦解的余波中。是的。查理，他统治法兰克人。他是丕平的儿子，丕平自立为王，摆脱了墨洛温王朝的国王。他是查理·马特（伟大的军阀）的孙子。查理在拉丁语中是 Carolus。因此，丕平创立且查理曼所属的王朝被历史学家称为加洛林王朝。所以查理是顶级的加洛林人，他是顶级的法兰克人。老实说，他是欧洲最顶尖的人物，因为
he has put the whole of the old heartlands of the Roman Empire in his shadow. And he is now pushing eastwards. I think that's an excellent poem that you read by Paulinus, who in due course, as we said, will go on to become a saint. This is celebrating the conquest and the conversion of the Saxons. These were a pagan people on the eastern flank of the Frankish Empire. Relations with the Franks had been terrible for ages and ages. They'd endlessly been raiding Frankish Empire. Relations with the Franks had been terrible for ages and ages. They'd endlessly been kind of raiding Frankish lands, nicking their cattle, all that kind of stuff. And this had been a kind of grumbling cause of complaint under the
他将罗马帝国整个旧核心地区都笼罩在自己的阴影之下。他现在正向东推进。我认为你朗读的保利努斯的诗非常棒，正如我们所说，他日后将成为圣人。这首诗是在庆祝对萨克逊人的征服和皈依。萨克逊人是法兰克帝国东翼的一个异教民族。长久以来，他们与法兰克人的关系一直极度恶劣。他们不断地袭击法兰克帝国。长久以来，他们与法兰克人的关系一直极度恶劣。他们不断地袭扰法兰克人的土地，掠夺他们的牛群等等。在墨洛温王朝统治时期，
Merovingians and then under the Carolingians. But Charlemagne, he's very much a guy for a radical solution. And he's piling right in and saying, okay, you know, I'm not going to put up with this. I'm going to conquer them. So he had gone to war against them in 772. So that's the year after he's become sole king. And this has lasted on and off for five years. And now it seems to Paulinus that Charlemagne has succeeded in his aims, that the Saxons are conquered. It's absolutely brilliant. And so he salutes Charlemagne. May God grant Clement Prince as his reward for achieving such a victory, the sweet pastures of eternal life. It's all looking good for Charlemagne.
以及后来的加洛林王朝时期，这一直是一个令人抱怨不断的原因。但查理曼非常倾向于采取激进的解决办法。他直接介入并说：“好吧，你知道的，我不会再容忍下去了。我要征服他们。”因此，他在 772 年对他们发动了战争。那是他成为唯一国王的后一年。这场战争断断续续持续了五年。现在保利努斯看来，查理曼已经达到了他的目标，萨克逊人被征服了。这绝对是太棒了。因此，他向查理曼致敬。愿上帝赐予这位仁慈的王子作为获得如此胜利的奖赏——永恒生命的甘甜牧场。这一切对查理曼来说都显得非常顺利。
That's nice. So people who might be a little bit confused, these are Saxons in what is now Germany. This is not Anglo-Saxons. Yes, so Saxony. Yeah, in Saxony. So lower Saxony, to give people a sort of sense that's the northern bit of kind of Western Germany at this point, though Saxony then... Yeah, kind of below Denmark. Yeah, exactly. Right. So Charlemagne, Tom, Charles the Great. He's a funny character, isn't he, Charlemagne? Lots of people have heard of Charlemagne, but I think it's fair to say that lots of people know no more about him than his name. So he is a new figure. He is an entirely sui generis, an exceptional figure
这很好。所以，可能会有点糊涂的人会问，这些是现在德国境内的萨克逊人。这不是盎格鲁-萨克逊人。是的，也就是萨克森。是的，在萨克森。所以下萨克森，给人们一种概念，那是当时西德北部的部分地区，虽然萨克森当时……是的，在丹麦下面。没错。好的。所以查理曼，汤姆，查理大帝。他是个有趣的人物，不是吗，查理曼？很多人都听说过查理曼，但我觉得公平地说，很多人对他的了解除了他的名字之外一无所知。所以他是一个全新的人物。他在欧洲历史上是一个完全独一无二、非凡的人物，
in European history because he's different from all the warlords who've gone before him. Am I right? He's not radically different. It's just that he is more impressive and he has more resources to draw on. And so therefore he can behave in a way that hasn't been seen in Western Europe for a very long time. So Peter Brown, the great historian of late antiquity, says of Charlemagne that he was not a warrior chieftain in a fragile epic mode. He trod with the heavy tread of a dominus, so a Roman lord, a Lord of Roman determination, capable of deploying resources on an almost Roman scale. And these resources are preeminently military because he has inherited from Pepin
因为他与在他之前的所有军阀都不同。我说的对吗？他并非有根本性的大不相同。只是他更加令人印象深刻，他拥有更多可调用的资源。因此，他的行事方式是西欧很长一段时间以来所未曾见多的。因此，晚期古典时代的伟大历史学家彼得·布朗（Peter Brown）这样评价查理曼：他不是一个处在脆弱史诗模式中的武士首领。他带着 dominus（即罗马领主）的沉重步伐前行，具有罗马式的坚定决心，能够以几乎罗马式的规模调配资源。这些资源主要是军事资源，因为他从丕平
and from his grandfather Charles Martel by far the most menacing war machine in Europe. But he adds to that some very, very kind of distinctive personal qualities. So in the previous episode, we heard from Einhard, who was this very short scholar who wrote a biography of Charlemagne. And Einhard summed up Charlemagne as having two particularly striking character traits. He said that he had greatness of soul and a constant firmness of mind. And I guess you could, if you were not as prone to praising Charlemagne as Einhard was, you could say that these qualities correspond perhaps to having very broad horizons, a capacity to see things on a very large scale,
以及他的祖父查理·马特那里继承了欧洲迄今为止最具威胁性的战争机器。但他为此增添了一些非常、非常独特的个人特质。所以在上一集中，我们听到了艾因哈德（Einhard）的讲述，他是一位身材矮小的学者，写了一部查理曼传记。艾因哈德总结说，查理曼有两个特别鲜明的性格特征。他说他具有伟大的灵魂和坚定不移的心智。我想，如果你不像艾因哈德那样倾向于赞美查理曼，你可能会说，这些品质也许对应着拥有极其宽广的视野、以宏大视角看待事物的能力，
and also a capacity to take a very, very long view. And to Einhard, these qualities remind him of perhaps the greatest of all Roman emperors, who is Augustus. And this is why Einhard models his biography on Suetonius' biography of Augustus. And there is something Roman about the approach that Charlemagne takes to the Saxons. So anyone who knows how the Romans behaved to the Germans, or indeed to the Gauls when they conquered them, they are murderous in their response to perceived slites or insults. And certainly Charlemagne's policy of outright conquest, we've got these kind of fractures barbarians, let's go and conquer them and pacify them. That is a very Roman approach. And there's an account from a chronicler describing Charlemagne's
以及采取非常、非常长远眼光的能力。对艾因哈德来说，这些品质让他想起了也许是所有罗马皇帝中最伟大的奥古斯都。这就是为什么艾因哈德以苏埃托尼乌斯的奥古斯都传记为蓝本撰写自己的传记。查理曼对待萨克逊人的方法中确实有一些罗马式的色彩。因此，任何了解罗马人如何对待日耳曼人，或者确实在征服高卢人时如何对待他们的人都知道，对于他们所认为的怠慢或侮辱，他们的反应是残暴的。当然，查理曼采取彻底征服的政策——我们这里有这些分裂的野蛮人，让我们去征服他们并安抚他们——这是一种非常罗马式的方法。有一位编年史家对查理曼
early campaigns against the Saxons. It will sound to people, I think, like the historians of Rome describing the onslaught of the legionaries against the barbarian people. This chronicler writes, Charles devastated the lands of the Saxons with fire and sword and left them emptied of people. When he targets a particularly celebrated Saxon shrine, he's described as destroying it utterly and taking away all the gold and silver he found there. And I think even when we say the Saxons, that again is a Frankish formulation that reflects the tendency that the Romans had, which was to kind of perceive pagan peoples, tribal peoples, peoples on the fringes of their civilization
早期针对萨克逊人的战役进行了描述。我想，这在人们听来，就像罗马历史学家在描述军团士兵对野蛮人发起的猛烈攻击一样。这位编年史家写道：查理用烈火和刀剑蹂躏了萨克逊人的土地，将其洗劫一空。当他把目标对准一个特别著名的萨克逊神殿时，据描述他将其彻底摧毁，并带走了他在那里发现的所有黄金和白银。而且我认为，即使当我们说“萨克逊人”时，那同样是一种法兰克人的表述，它反映了罗马人的一种倾向，即倾向于用他们所能理解的术语来
in terms that they would understand. And of course, that's what the Romans had done to the Franks. And now the Franks are doing it to these people that they kind of bundle together as Saxons. So sort of sticking labels on people, very Roman thing to do, to kind of classify people and say these are these people and they have red hair and these are their habits and all that kind of thing. Yes. On the Franks, so the Franks presumably now at this point, Charlemagne very much sees himself as the heir, doesn't he, to the Roman inheritance,
看待异教民族、部落民族以及他们文明边缘的人民。当然，罗马人对法兰克人就是这么做的。现在法兰克人正对这些被他们统称为萨克逊人的人群这样做。所以，给人们贴上标签，这是非常罗马的做法，把人群分类，并说这些人是这样的人，他们有红头发，这些是他们的习惯诸如此类的事情。是的。关于法兰克人，那么法兰克人大概在这个时候，查理曼非常将自己视为罗马遗产的继承人，不是吗？
do you think? I think he does. I mean, not actually to Augustus, but to the Christian emperors who had ruled a great Christian realm. And of course, that is one point of difference between Charlemagne and Augustus is that Charlemagne is, you know, he's not just a great conqueror, but he is a Christian conqueror. And there's a kind of quality of paradox to that because there hasn't really been such a figure before. So when he advances into the lands of the Saxons, he's not aiming just to conquer them. He wants to save their souls. He wants to bring them to Christ. And this great shrine that I described Charlemagne as destroying in 772, it's not just that it's rich. It's
你觉得呢？我想他是的。我的意思不是指实际继承奥古斯都，而是继承那些统治过伟大基督教王国的基督教皇帝。当然，查理曼与奥古斯都的一点不同之处在于，查理曼不仅是一个伟大的征服者，他还是一个基督教征服者。这其中有一种悖论的特质，因为以前并没有真正出现过这样的人物。因此，当他推进到萨克逊人的土地时，他的目的不仅是征服他们。他是为了拯救他们的灵魂。他想把他们带向基督。我刚才描述查理曼在 772 年摧毁的那座宏伟神殿，不仅因为它很富裕，
obviously the fact that it is a pagan shrine. It's fearsome. It's phallic. It's basically a massive great pole sticking up out of the Saxon earth, famed across Saxony and believed by the Saxons to uphold the very heavens themselves. Charlemagne chops it down to demonstrate that this isn't true, that it has no sacral potency whatsoever. And I guess even the looting of its treasures can be justified in terms of what churchmen in Charlemagne's realm are coming to describe as a process of correctio. So it's a Latin word, which means the bringing of order where there is disorder, burnishing what has been besmeared and besmirched.
显然还因为它是一座异教神殿。它令人敬畏，具有男性生殖崇拜的特征。它基本上是从萨克逊土地上拔地而起的一根巨大柱子，在整个萨克森闻名遐迩，萨克逊人相信它支撑着整个天空。查理曼将其砍倒，以证明这不是真的，它根本没有任何神圣的效力。我想，甚至对它的财宝进行掠夺，也可以用查理曼王国内部的教会人士开始称之为“矫正”（correctio）过程来证明其正当性。这是一个拉丁语词，意思是让无序的地方恢复秩序，将那些被玷污和抹黑的东西擦拭干净。
And can I at this point quote from myself, from Millennium? Do. So this program, here was a program to wet the ambitions of warlords as well as scholars and to send men into battle beneath the fluttering of banners, the hiss of arrows and the shadow of carrion crows quite as much as into the mildewed quiet of libraries. And is that you or is that Paul Inus? Well, very hard to tell us apart, I think. You can see that he's been a great influence
此时我能否引用我自己的书《千年》中的话？请便。所以这个节目，这里有一个能够激起军阀以及学者野心并让男人们在旗帜飘扬、箭矢呼号和食腐乌鸦的阴影下投入战斗，其程度丝毫不亚于投入图书馆发霉般宁静的节目。这是你写的还是保利努斯写的？嗯，很难把我们区分开来，我想。你可以看出他对我
on my prose. But there is this idea that Charlemagne cleaves to very, very passionately that in bringing sword and fire to the lands of the Saxons, he is also bringing order and essentially it's all for their own good. It's all for their own benefit. But Saxony is not the only place that he's looking at, is he? Because he's looking beyond the frontiers of what was once Gaul, which is now Francia, and he's also looking to Italy, isn't he? Because Italy is still a bit of a lodestar for people who are living in the ruins of the Roman Empire, the inheritance of Rome and so on. So what's going on in Italy? Italy is now under the sway of the Lombards. Is that right?
的散文产生了很大的影响。但确实存在这样一种观念，查理曼对此坚信不疑：在给萨克逊人的土地带去刀剑和烈火的同时，他也带来了秩序，从根本上讲，这一切都是为了他们自己的好。这一切都是为了他们自己的利益。但萨克森并不是他唯一关注的地方，对吧？因为他不仅将目光投向了曾经是高卢、现在是法兰克（Francia）的边境之外，他还将目光投向了意大利，不是吗？因为对于生活在罗马帝国废墟中、罗马遗产继承人等之中的人来说，意大利仍然是一个指路明灯。那么意大利发生了什么？意大利现在受伦巴第人的统治。是这样吗？
Well, in the previous episode, we heard how the Pope in Rome, he had anointed Charlemagne's father, thereby providing him with the religious legitimacy that he wanted. him with the religious legitimacy that he wanted. So it's become very important to the Carolingians. The papacy basically has licensed them to become kings. So a very important figure. But he's been menaced by the Lombards. And essentially the quid pro quo between the Carolingians and the papacy is that the Pope will anoint kings and all that kind of stuff. And meanwhile, the Carolingians are expected to keep the Lombards, who are these very important people in the north of Italy, keep them on a kind of tight leash. And Charlemagne, whose ambitions are clearly considerable in a way that not even his fathers had been, even when he's in Saxony, is thinking about what could I do against the Lombards? I mean, maybe I could just swallow up their kingdom. And so when he strips this great pagan shrine of all
嗯，在上一集中，我们听到罗马教皇如何为查理曼的父亲涂圣油，从而赋予了他所渴望的宗教合法性。从而赋予了他所渴望的宗教合法性。因此，这对于加洛林王朝变得非常重要。教皇基本上授权他们成为国王。所以这是一个非常重要的人物。但他一直受到伦巴第人的威胁。从本质上讲，加洛林王朝和教皇之间的对等条件是教皇将为国王涂圣油诸如此类的事情。与此同时，加洛林王朝则需要看管好伦巴第人——这些在意大利北部非常重要的人，把他们控制在一个相对紧密的范围内。而查理曼的野心显然相当巨大，甚至超越了他的父亲，当他在萨克森时，他也在考虑我对伦巴第人能做些什么。我的意思是，也许我可以把他们的王国整个吞并。因此，当他剥夺这座伟大的异教神殿的
its treasure, I think he is thinking, you know, this is great. I can use this to essentially fund a war against the Lombards. And he will need it because the Lombards occupy a stretch of land that is dotted, as you said, with ancient Roman cities, have walls that are impressive. The Lombards are a kingdom a bit like the Franks, I mean, on a smaller scale, but kind of a challenge of a different order to the Saxons. And they're also Germanic, is that right, the Lombards? They are Germanic. They command the Alpine passes, so that's a potential problem. And
所有宝藏时，我想他在想：“太棒了。我可以用这些来基本上资助一场反对伦巴第人的战争。”他会需要这些的，因为伦巴第人占据了一片土地，正如你所说，这片土地上星罗棋布着古罗马城市，拥有令人印象深刻的城墙。伦巴第人是一个有点像法兰克人的王国——我的意思是规模较小——但对萨克森人来说是不同性质的挑战。而且他们也是日耳曼人，对吗，伦巴第人？他们是日耳曼人。他们控制着阿尔卑斯山的山口，所以这是一个潜在的问题。而且
there is also bad blood between Charlemagne and the Lombard king, who's a man called Desiderius, because Charlemagne had been married to the daughter of Desiderius for a year and then basically had dumped her, I think for diplomatic reasons rather than personal reasons, because he needed to marry someone else from Central Europe. And Desiderius also is harbouring a rival claimant to the throne of Francia. So basically when this bloke died of a nosebleed, Charlemagne's brother, Carloman, his wife and sons had gone off and taken refuge with the Lombards, hadn't they? Yes.
查理曼与伦巴第国王之间也存在宿怨，伦巴第国王是一个叫德西德里乌斯（Desiderius）的人。因为查理曼曾娶了德西德里乌斯的女儿一年，然后基本上把她抛弃了，我想这是出于外交原因而不是个人原因，因为他需要娶一个来自中欧的其他人。而且德西德里乌斯还在庇护法兰克王位的竞争对手。所以基本上，当这个因流鼻血而死的人——查理曼的兄弟卡洛曼——其妻子和儿子逃走并在伦巴第人那里避难时，难道不是吗？是的。
So that's a bit of a worry for Charlemagne that the wife and the sons are hanging around in what's now Lombardy. Well, I think that is probably actually the biggest consideration of all, because Charlemagne knows that the one thing that could really cripple his offensive capacity and the integrity of his empire is kind of factional rivalry with rival members of his own family. And we know that this is weighing on his mind because we have a life of Hadrian I, who's become Pope shortly after Charlemagne's come to power. And in this biography, it says that the wife and sons of the late Charlemagne king of the Franks had taken refuge with Desidius, who was trying hard to make good his contention that these princes should assume the kingship of the Franks in the hope of stirring up dissensions
所以这对查理曼来说有点令人担忧，他的妻子和儿子在现在的伦巴第到处闲逛。嗯，我认为这可能实际上是最重要的考量，因为查理曼知道，唯一真正会削弱他的进攻能力和帝国完整性的事情，就是与他自己家族中对立成员的派系竞争。我们知道这件事一直压在他的心头，因为我们有一部关于哈德良一世（Hadrian I）生平的著作，他在查理曼掌权后不久就成为了教皇。在这部传记中，它说已故法兰克国王查理曼的妻子和儿子在德西德里乌斯那里找到了庇护，德西德里乌斯正竭力为主张这些王子应该继承法兰克王位提供正当理由，
in the kingdom of the Franks. And in fact, Desiderius writes to the Pope and says, look, I've got these two boys, crown them, you know, anoint them, give them your legitimacy. Hadrian refuses because, you refuses because he essentially has to weigh up which of these two guys is likelier to win. And he decides that Charlemagne is the likelier. But he's still in an awkward position because Desiderius is between him and Charlemagne. And in fact, when Hadrian sends a messenger to Charlemagne saying, please come to my rescue, I'm being menaced, He can't actually use the Alpine passes because they've been shut off. And so he has to send the messenger via Marseilles, which then goes up to Charlemagne. And when Charlemagne gets this message, it
以期在法兰克王国中挑起不和。事实上，德西德里乌斯写信给教皇说：“听着，我有这两个男孩，为他们加冕吧，你知道的，为他们涂圣油，赋予他们你的合法性。”哈德良拒绝了，因为他基本上必须权衡这两个人中哪一个更有可能获胜。他认为查理曼更有可能。但他仍然处在一个尴尬的境地，因为德西德里乌斯挡在了他和查理曼之间。事实上，当哈德良派信使去见查理曼说“请来救救我，我受到威胁”时，他实际上无法使用阿尔卑斯山的山口，因为它们已经被封锁了。因此，他不得不通过马赛派遣信使，然后再转交到查理曼手中。当查理曼收到这个消息时，它
confirms his worst anxieties, essentially that Desiderius will be using these two nephews to strike at him. And so he thinks, okay, I've got to go to war. So the summer of 773, Charles summons his peers, his warriors, his advisors to Geneva in Switzerland, holds a great council there. He wants to get the support of his followers for the war that's to come. And then having got that, he advances southwards. He seizes control of the two main mountain passes over the Alps. Once he's done that, he then sends ambassadors to Desiderius. You can see what his main target is because even at this point, his prime anxiety is to get hold of the nephews. He says to Desiderius, look, I am willing to hold off war and I'm willing to pay you a frankly enormous amount of money if you will hand these boys over
证实了他最糟糕的焦虑，基本上就是德西德里乌斯会利用这两个侄子来打击他。因此他想：“好吧，我必须开战。”所以在 773 年的夏天，查理召集他的贵族、他的武士、他的谋士前往瑞士日内瓦，并在那里举行了一场盛大的会议。他希望为即将到来的战争获得追随者的支持。在获得支持后，他向南挺进。他夺取了翻越阿尔卑斯山的两个主要山隘的控制权。一旦完成这些，他便派遣大使去见德西德里乌斯。你可以看出他的主要目标是什么，因为即使在此时，他首要的焦虑也是抓住这两个侄子。他对德西德里乌斯说：“听着，我愿意暂缓战争，如果你肯把这些男孩交给我，
to me." And Desiderius refuses. And Charlemagne, I think, is really quite surprised by this. Janet Nelson, in her brilliant biography of Charlemagne, offers an explanation for why Desiderius should have refused Charlemagne's offer. She writes, Charles underestimated one thing that was beyond price, the Lombard king's honor. What father does deals with the man who has repudiated his daughter? And she speaks the truth there. Do you think that's plausible? I mean, Charlemagne is a man of raial politique and so is Desiderius. Do you think Desiderius really is thinking, oh, I'm just really bitter about this family
我愿意支付给你一笔坦白说数额巨大的钱。”而德西德里乌斯拒绝了。我认为查理曼对此感到相当惊讶。珍妮特·纳尔逊（Janet Nelson）在她那部精彩的查理曼传记中，为德西德里乌斯为何拒绝查理曼的提议提供了一种解释。她写道：查理低估了一件无价之宝——伦巴第国王的荣誉。哪个父亲会和一个抛弃了他女儿的男人做交易？她说得没错。你认为这合理吗？我的意思是，查理曼是一个现实政治（realpolitik）的人，德西德里乌斯也是。你认为德西德里乌斯真的在想：“哦，我对这场家庭纠纷感到非常痛苦。”而这是他做决定时最大的因素？还是你认为他觉得：“不，我宁愿抓住这些男孩，因为他们对我有如此强大的政治筹码？”我认为两者兼有。我想，如果他的荣誉没有受到侮辱，也许他会拿钱并谋求和平。真的吗？好吧。
row. And that's the single biggest thing in his decision-making. Or do you think he thinks, no, I'd rather keep a hold of these boys because they're such a powerful political pawn for me? I think a bit of both. I think if his honor had not been insulted, perhaps he might've taken the money and settled for peace. Really? Okay. Yes, I think so. I think the sense that he's been shamed before the eyes of his own people and of Christian Europe generally was clearly very strong. And so he decides that he's going to fight. And so war breaks out.'s going to fight. And so war breaks out. Charles descends from the Alps into Northern Italy. And his immediate target is
是的，我想是这样的。我认为在自己的人民和整个基督教欧洲面前受辱的感觉显然非常强烈。因此他决定战斗。于是战争爆发了。查理从阿尔卑斯山下降临到意大利北部。他直接的目标是
Pavia, because that is where Desiderius has set himself up. But it's also because according to reports, that is where the two nephews are, the two princes, who I'm sure have been kept in a tower. However, when he gets there, Charlemagne finds that he's too late, that the princes have been sent away to Verona. And so he splits his forces. So the life of Hadrian the Pope, we're told Charles left most of his forces at Pavia with a number of his bravest Franks moved rapidly towards Verona. And this is a move that clearly takes the defenders of Verona by surprise. And Karlaman's sons and his wife, who has the brilliant name of Geberga, they all surrender themselves to Charlemagne. Although,
帕维亚（Pavia），因为那是德西德里乌斯安营扎寨的地方。但这也是因为据报告，那两个侄子——那两位我确信被关在塔里的王子——也在那里。然而，当他到达那里时，查理曼发现自己来晚了，王子们已经被送到维罗纳（Verona）去了。因此他分兵了。因此，根据教皇哈德良的传记，我们得知查理将大部分军队留在帕维亚，只带着他的一些最勇敢的法兰克人迅速向维罗纳进发。这个举动显然让维罗纳的防御者措手不及。卡洛曼的儿子们和他的妻子——一个有着杰出名字热伯加（Geberga）的女性——他们全都向查理曼投降了。尽管，
according to the life of Hadrian, Karlaman's wives and sons immediately handed themselves over of their own free wills. It sounds slightly like there's some special pleading going on. And the intriguing thing is that from this point on, that is the last dimension of them. Will Barron And there were two boys, right? Two boys boys and the last we heard of them there in Verona. So they ended their lives literally as two gentlemen of Verona. Well, I mean, they may have been tonsured, so had their hair shaved off and packed off to the monastery, but if they were, we don't hear about it. They're probably being killed. They're being killed.
根据哈德良的传记，卡洛曼的妻子和儿子们是立刻自愿投降的。听起来好像里面有些诡辩的成分。而耐人寻味的是，从那时起，那是关于他们的最后记录。威廉·巴伦（Will Barron）而且有两个男孩对吧？两个男孩，我们听到的关于他们的最后消息是在维罗纳。所以他们的生命真正结束时就像维罗纳的两个绅士。嗯，我的意思是，他们可能被剃度了，也就是头发被剃光并被塞进了修道院，但如果是这样的话，我们没有听到相关消息。他们可能被杀了。他们被杀了。
I mean, maybe Charlemagne Richard III did. I mean, we don't know. Right. Well, that's the end of them. What's going on in Pavia? The siege there is still continuing, right? Yes, right the way through the winter, Desiderius holding out. And Charles seems to have had a slight wobble. He abandons the siege and he goes south to Rome. So it's his first visit to Rome. And he goes to St Peter's tomb and he prays there. And whether it is for St Peter to intercede with God to help him in the siege, or maybe, I mean, maybe it's the expression of a guilty conscience. Yeah. Maybe he feels bad about what he's done to his nephews, we don't know. But it's clearly the case
我的意思是，也许查理曼就像理查三世那样做了。我的意思是，我们不知道。好吧，他们就这样结束了。帕维亚那边发生了什么？那里的围城战还在继续，对吧？是的，整个冬天，德西德里乌斯都在苦苦支撑。而查理似乎有些动摇。他放弃了围城，向南去了罗马。所以这是他第一次访问罗马。他去了圣彼得墓并在那里祈祷。无论这是为了让圣彼得在上帝面前代求以帮助他攻城，还是也许——我的意思是，也许这是良心受谴责的表现。是的。也许他对他对侄子们做的事感到内疚，我们不得而知。但显然的情况是，
that when he goes back to Pavia, his morale has been boosted, he's back in the saddle, he's full of vigor, and he prosecutes the siege with a kind of renewed sense of aggression. And if he was praying for God's assistance, then God gives it because a terrible plague breaks out in Pavia, and it causes such devastation that Desiderius basically surrenders. He has no choice. Wow. So again, quoting from the life of Hadrian, the wrath of God raged and stormed against all the Lombards in that city. And they were so enfeebled by disease and death that the excellent King of the Franks captured the
当他回到帕维亚时，他的士气大振，他重回马鞍，充满了活力，并以一种重新焕发出的侵略感继续推进围城。如果他是祈求上帝的援助，那么上帝确实给予了援助，因为帕维亚爆发了一场可怕的瘟疫，它造成的破坏如此之大，以至于德西德里乌斯基本上投降了。他别无选择。哇。所以再次引用哈德良传记中的话：“上帝的愤怒向那座城市的所有伦巴第人猛烈倾泻并肆虐。他们被疾病和死亡折磨得如此虚弱，以至于法兰克人的卓越国王夺取了
city together with Desiderius. And that essentially is the end, not just of Desiderius' ambitions, but of the independence of the Lombard kingdom. And Desiderius is taken back to Frankia. He is tonsured. He is sent to a monastery. And Lombardy, the kingdom isn't erased. Charlemagne becomes king of the Lombards. So from this point on, he is described in his charters as king of the Franks and of the Lombards. But Lombardy is now clearly a part of Charlemagne's empire and his power now extends right the way to Rome. So it's a significant advance of the Frankish frontier. And to put that into context, he is the first bloke, presumably, to rule
这座城市以及德西德里乌斯。”这基本上不仅是德西德里乌斯野心的终结，也是伦巴第王国独立的终结。德西德里乌斯被带回法兰克。他被剃度。他被送进了一座修道院。伦巴第——这个王国并没有被抹去。查理曼成为了伦巴第国王。因此，从那时起，他在宪章中被描述为法兰克人与伦巴第人之王。但伦巴第现在显然是查理曼帝国的一部分，他的权力现在一直延伸到罗马。所以这是法兰克边境的重大推进。把这放在背景中来看，他大概是两百年来第一位在法兰克以及意大利北部毫无争议地进行统治的人吧？大概？哦，我的意思是，甚至更久。我的意思是，追溯到西罗马帝国灭亡时期。
unchallenged in Gaul and certainly the top half of Italy for what, 200 years? Maybe? Oh, I mean, even longer. I mean, back to the time of fall of the Roman empire in the West. Yeah. The Alps had always been the kind of frontier. So the early fifth century. Yeah. So that's an extraordinary achievement. It is. And when you consider that on top of that, at this point, he thinks he's conquered Saxony,
是的。所以那是多么非凡的成就。确实如此。当你考虑到除此之外，在这个时候，他认为自己已经征服了萨克森，
and those are reaches of land that the Caesar's hadn't even ruled. I mean, he's starting to look very, very impressive. And the truth is that Charlemagne is a very great war leader. Indeed, he leads his men personally into battle, he conducts campaigns personally. The strategy is all his. And it's very rare that there isn't a campaign being fought somewhere on the frontiers of the Frankish realm. So in 790, one of the annals of Charlemagne's reign, so these are histories that record the doings in terms of what happened each year. The entry for 790 is simply the Franks did nothing, i.e. they didn't go to war. This is the shortest entry we have in this annal. And it reflects the fact this is an amazing thing. There
而那是连凯撒大帝都未曾统治过的土地。我的意思是，他开始显得非常、非常令人印象深刻。事实是，查理曼是一位非常伟大的军事领袖。事实上，他亲自率领部下投入战斗，亲自指挥战役。战略全由他定。法兰克王国的边境某处总是在进行战役，这种情况非常罕见。因此，在 790 年，查理曼统治时期的其中一部编年史——也就是记录每年所做事情的历史——对 790 年的条目非常简单：法兰克人什么也没做，即他们没有去打仗。这是我们在部编年史中看到的最短的条目。它反映了一个惊人的事实：这一年没有战争。这是唯一一次发生这种情况。所以每年都有军事行动。
were no wars this year. It's the only time it happens. So every other year there is military action. And it is taking place on all the various frontiers of Charlemagne's empire. So the Spain, so we talked in the episode we did on the Battle of Tours and in the previous one about how the Frankish kings have been pushing, let's call them the Arabs, back from the Loire, back beyond the Pyrenees and Charlemagne actually crosses the Pyrenees and takes the fight to the Arabs in Spain itself. He captures the town of Pamplona, pulls down its walls so that it can't be used against him. And then he returns across the Pyrenees. And this is a retreat that is very,
而且它发生在查理曼帝国的各个边境上。比如西班牙，我们在图尔战役的那期节目中以及之前的那期节目中讨论过，法兰克国王如何将阿拉伯人从卢瓦尔河推回比利牛斯山脉之外，而查理曼实际上跨越了比利牛斯山脉，将战火烧到了西班牙本土的阿拉伯人身上。他攻占了潘普洛纳（Pamplona）镇，推倒了它的城墙，使其无法被用来对抗他。然后他穿回比利牛斯山脉。这次撤退非常、
very famous because as his rear guard, which is guarding his baggage, is going through the pass of Roces Valles, Rocevo, it is ambushed and the baggage is taken. The commander of this baggage train, who is one of Charlemagne's palatini, so the people who attend him in his palace, paladins, as they will come to be called, Roland the great paladin, he has a horn and he blows on the horn to signal to Charlemagne the disaster that is befalling him. And this will become the theme of one of the great, great medieval epics. I mean, it's a wonderful story and we could perhaps at some point do an episode on it, but it's not strictly relevant to the life of Charlemagne himself because
非常著名，因为当他的后卫部队——负责保护他的辎重——穿过隆塞斯瓦列斯山口（Roncesvalles, Rocevo）时，遭到了伏击，辎重被夺。这支辎重部队的指挥官是查理曼的宫廷近卫军（palatini）之一，也就是那些在宫殿里伺候他的人，后来被称为圣骑士（paladins）——伟大的圣骑士罗兰（Roland）有一个号角，他吹响号角向查理曼发出灾难降临的信号。这将成为中世纪最伟大的史诗之一的主题。我的意思是，这是一个精彩的故事，我们也许可以在某个时候做一期关于它的节目，但它与查理曼本人的生平并不是绝对相关，因为
all of that romance is massively overblown. It's not the great disaster that the poets would make it seem. Although having said that, I mean, it's obviously not brilliant that he's lost overblown. It's not the great disaster that the poets would make it seem. Although having said that, I mean, it's obviously not brilliant that he's lost all his luggage. No. And actually, from that point on, Charlemagne is pretty much content to leave the Pyrenees alone, at least until the beginning of the ninth century, as we will see. But his real focus is Central Europe, right? Yes, it is.
所有这些浪漫色彩都被大大夸大了。它并不是诗人们所描绘的那场大灾难。话虽如此，我的意思是，他丢了所有的行李显然不是什么光彩的事。不。事实上，从那时起，查理曼基本上满足于不管比利牛斯山脉，至少直到九世纪初，正如我们将会看到的。但他真正的重点是中欧，对吧？是的，确实如此。
So Central Europe, there's another people who are called the Avars, who are based in what's now Hungary on the great plain of Pannonia. They are horse lords of the plains, aren't they? They are. So they're a bit like the Hums. You know, they fire bows and arrows from horses. That's their thing. They are not a Germanic people, are they, the Avars?
所以中欧，还有另一个民族叫做阿瓦尔人（Avars），他们以现在的匈牙利潘诺尼亚大平原为基地。他们是平原上的马背领主，对吧？他们是的。所以他们有点像匈人。你知道的，他们从马上发射弓箭。那是他们的特色。阿瓦尔人不是日耳曼民族，对吧？
Aren't they kind of Turkic or something like that? Maybe nomads from further east. Anyway, they're causing all kinds of trouble in Northern Italy, in Germany, they're kind of ranging around and raiding and doing all this kind of thing. And Charlemagne decides they're his focus. He's going to deal with them. Well the thing is that I think for a long time the assumption has been among people like the Avars that it's cost free to go and raid a monastery or something or to attack a town. There's
他们是不是有点像突尔克人（Turkic）或者诸如此类的？也许是来自更东方的游民。总之，他们在意大利北部、德国制造了各种麻烦，四处游荡、劫掠并做着各种各样的事情。而查理曼决定他们就是他的焦点。他要对付他们。嗯，问题在于，我想很长一段时间以来，像阿瓦尔人这样的人一直有一种假设，即去洗劫一座修道院或者袭击一个城镇是没有代价的。
nothing anyone can really do about it because they're so mobile. But this isn't Charlemagne's perspective at all. If people raid his kingdom, then he's going to go after them. And so that's exactly what he does. And in 791, he leads what seems to be a very intimidating invasion, which he then has to abandon because there's a massive horse plague. So all his horses, about 90% it's estimated of his horses get wiped out. And this seems to be really bad for him. However, it's much worse in the long run for the Avars, because of course, the plague spreads to Pannonia. And if they lose their horses, then they're completely screwed, because without horses, they can't do anything. Their entire offensive capability depends on their ability to shoot
因为他们机动性极强，没有人能真正对此做些什么。但这根本不是查理曼的看法。如果有人袭击他的王国，他就会去追击他们。这正是他所做的。在 791 年，他领导了一场看起来极具威慑力的入侵，但随后由于爆发了一场严重的马瘟，他不得不放弃。因此，他所有的马——估计大约有 90% 的马——都死光了。这对他来说似乎真的很糟糕。然而，从长远来看，这对阿瓦尔人来说更糟，因为当然，瘟疫蔓延到了潘诺尼亚。如果他们失去了马匹，那么他们就彻底完蛋了，因为没有马匹，他们什么也做不了。他们全部的进攻能力都取决于他们在马鞍上射箭的能力。因此，到 790 年代中期，阿瓦尔人不仅受到法兰克人的袭扰，他们的王国也开始内部崩溃。
arrows from the saddle. So by the mid-790s, the Avars are being harried by the Franks, but their kingdom is starting to implode. So in 795, the Avar Khagan, so the kind of Avar Chieftain, is killed by his own men. One of his deputies then opens negotiations with Charlemagne, writes to him to surrender his land, his people, and himself to the king and to accept the Christian faith at the king's command. A Frankish strike force then advances against the great central palace of the Khagan. It's called the Ring, a great kind of structure full of all the loot that's been taken from Northern Italy and from Bavaria. And the Franks take the
所以在 795 年，阿瓦尔可汗——也就是阿瓦尔人的首领——被自己人杀害了。他的一位副手随后与查理曼展开了谈判，写信向国王投降他的土地、他的人民和他自己，并奉国王之命接受基督教信仰。一支法兰克突击队随后向可汗的巨大中央宫殿推进。它被称为“环形堡垒”（the Ring），这是一个巨大的建筑结构，里面装满了从意大利北部和巴伐利亚掠夺来的所有战利品。法兰克人拿走了
whole lot and they pile it onto great wagons and it's driven back to Charlemagne's court back in Austrasia, the Eastern Frankish kingdom. And Einhard probably saw it, Charlemagne's biographer, because he gives us a description of all this treasure coming into town, drawn in 15 carts, each pulled by four oxen and carrying great piles of gold and silver and precious robes of silk. And Einhard thinks this is great. He describes Charlemagne's victory over the Avars as the greatest and most terrible that he ever fought, but with one exception. And that exception is the war that Charlemagne fought against the Saxons. Because in fact, the hope that Charlemagne had had and that Paulinus had had when writing
全部战利品，把它们装上大车，运回了查理曼位于东法兰克王国奧斯特拉西亚（Austrasia）的宫廷。查理曼的传记作者艾因哈德可能亲眼见过，因为他为我们描绘了所有这些宝藏进入城镇的场景，它们由 15 辆大车拉着，每辆车由四头公牛拉着，载着成堆的金银和华丽的丝绸长袍。艾因哈德认为这太棒了。他将查理曼对阿瓦尔人的胜利描述为他经历过的最大、最可怕的胜利，但有一个例外。这个例外就是查理曼对萨克森人进行的战争。因为事实上，查理曼曾抱有的希望，以及保利努斯在写
that poem, that the war against the Saxons was over, that they had accepted defeat and had accepted baptism. This proves to be massively over-optimistic because in fact, the war rages for decades. It rages for decades for the same reason that the Romans had found it so hard to conquer Germany because despite their overwhelming military strength, the Franks find it a real struggle to kind of pin their opponents down, to force them to accept defeat once and for all. Is that because the Saxons don't have a capital, they don't have state structures, their tribal confederation? So how can you ever beat them, I guess?
那首诗时所抱有的希望——即对萨克森人的战争已经结束，他们已经接受了战败并接受了洗礼——事实证明这极度过于乐观。因为事实上，这场战争持续了数十年。它持续了数十年，原因与罗马人发现很难征服德国的原因相同：尽管法兰克人拥有压倒性的军事力量，但他们发现很难将对手钉死，很难迫使他们彻底接受失败。这是因为萨克森人没有首都，没有国家结构，他们只是部落联盟？所以我想你永远无法真正击败他们？
Yeah. And this ultimately is what had defeated the Romans. But Charlemagne in a way, I mean, his policy is kind of even more unyielding, even more unstinting, even more merciless than the Romans had been. So pretty much every spring, the Franks are riding out to harry the Saxons. If they've broken treaties, then they will be punished really brutally. Every autumn before they retreat back to their bases, the Franks torch the harvests of the Saxons so that they will then starve through the winter. Wherever they find a settlement in a rebellious area, they will torch it. And from 795 onwards, and again, this is very Roman, the Franks adopt a policy of mass deportations. So they are taking entire people's entire communities and transporting them deep into the Frankish empire. When they capture the Saxon elites, they're taking them as hostages, which again is very kind of Roman, and bringing them back to
是的。而这最终正是击败罗马人的原因。但查理曼的方式——从某种意义上说，他的政策比罗马人更加毫不妥协、更加毫无保留、更加冷酷无情。因此，几乎每年春天，法兰克人都骑马出征去袭扰萨克森人。如果萨克逊人打破了条约，他们就会受到极其残酷的惩罚。每年秋天在撤回基地之前，法兰克人都会焚烧萨克逊人的庄稼，以便他们在冬天挨饿。无论他们在叛乱地区发现定居点，他们都会将其付之一炬。从 795 年开始，同样非常罗马化的是，法兰克人采取了大规模驱逐的政策。因此，他们将整个民族、整个社区转移并运送到法兰克帝国的腹地。当他们俘虏萨克森精英时，他们把他们当作人质——这同样非常罗马化——把他们带回
Charlemagne's court and kind of educating them as Christians. And as I say, these are atrocities on a Roman scale. But the truth is that Charlemagne's inspiration is probably not Roman, but in the Old Testament, because the Pope, when he had crowned Pepin, Charlemagne's father, had hailed the Franks as a new Israel. And the example of Israelite warfare actually offers a king like Charlemagne, who wants to extirpate a pagan people quite a lot of inspiration. So in 7-8-2, there's a famous atrocity after a particularly violent uprising by Saxons who had supposedly accepted baptism and submitted to Charlemagne and then kind of turn against the Amaskar priests, destroy churches and all of that. So Charlemagne orders that 4,500 prisoners be beheaded on a single day. And the likelihood is that in ordering this punishment, he is inspired by the example of King David in the Old Testament, who similarly,
查理曼的宫廷，并将他们作为基督徒来教育。正如我所说，这些是罗马规模的暴行。但事实是，查理曼的灵感可能不是来自罗马，而是来自《旧约》，因为教皇在为查理曼的父亲丕平加冕时，曾将法兰克人誉为“新以色列”。以色列人战争的样板实际上给了一位像查理曼这样想要根除异教民族的国王相当多的启发。所以在 782 年，发生了一场著名的暴行，起因是据称已经接受洗礼并向查理曼投降的萨克逊人发生了一场特别暴力的起义，随后他们背叛了神职人员、摧毁了教堂以及所有这些。于是查理曼下令在一天之内斩首 4,500 名战俘。极有可能的是，他在下达这一惩罚时，受到了《旧约》中大卫王的启发，大卫王也曾以类似的方式——
we have this description in the Bible, every two lengths of captives were put to death and the third length was allowed to live. So it may be that there were even more prisoners and Charlemagne spared those. If you're behaving in a biblical way, that's fine, isn't it? Well, Roman and biblical, I mean, it's the fusing of the two great inspirations on the Carolingians. He's bringing it to bear on the Saxons. And it's a prosecution of total warfare on a scale that is so brutal that by the late 790s, Saxon resistance finally is starting to be broken. This is a victory of an order that the Romans in Germany never really succeeded in winning. To that extent, Charlemagne can celebrate it. But of course, there is an obvious and unsettling question that is hanging over the entire war and particularly the particularly brutal strategy that Charlemagne's been adopting in the kind of final decade of that war,
我们在圣经中看到了这样的描述：每两部分俘虏被处死，第三部分被允许活下来。所以可能当时有更多的囚犯，而查理曼饶了他们。如果你按照圣经的方式行事，那就没问题了，对吧？嗯，罗马和圣经的，我的意思是，这是对加洛林王朝两大灵感源泉的融合。他正将其施加于萨克森人身上。这是一场总体战，其规模极其残酷，以至于到了790年代末，萨克森人的抵抗终于开始被瓦解。这是一场罗马人在德国从未真正成功取得过的胜利。从这个意义上讲，查理曼可以为此庆祝。但是，当然，有一个显而易见且令人不安的问题一直悬在整场战争的上方，尤其是查理曼在那场战争的最后一个十年里所采取的那种极其残酷的策略之上，
which is that the triumph might be worthy of Augustus, but is it worthy of a Christian? You know, what does Christ think about all this? And this really matters to Charlemagne because Charlemagne is a very devout Christian. And what he is doing, he's doing as that poem written by Paul Innes suggested that you quoted at the beginning of the show, he's doing it in the hope of winning eternal life. And what if the violence and the horror that he's inflicted actually is opening the gates of hell to him? And that is a very pressing question. What if? Well, let's find out after the break whether he's going to get eternal life or whether he's going to hell. See you then. Headphones offer best-in-class noise cancellation and an enhanced sound range, making them perfect for enjoying music and podcasts. Get up to 55 hours of listening with active noise-cancelling enabled, soft microfiber
那就是，这场胜利或许配得上奥古斯都，但它配得上一个基督徒吗？你知道，基督对这一切怎么看？这对查理曼来说真的很重要，因为查理曼是一个非常虔诚的基督徒正如保罗·伊内斯在那首诗中所暗示的、你在节目开始时引用过的那样，他所做的一切，都是为了赢得永生。如果他所造成的暴力和恐怖实际上正在为他打开地狱之门呢？这是一个非常迫切的问题。如果呢？好吧，让我们在休息之后拭目以待，看看他能否获得永生，还是会下地狱。到时候见。耳机提供同类最佳的降噪功能和增强的音域，使其成为欣赏音乐和播客的绝佳选择。在启用主动降噪的情况下，聆听时间长达55小时，柔软的超细纤维
cushions engineered for comfort, and a range of colors and finishes. Dyson On Track. Headphones remastered. Buy from DysonCanada.ca. With ANC on, performance may vary based on environmental conditions and usage. Accessories sold separately. With ANC on, performance may vary based on environmental conditions and usage, accessories sold separately. Miami Metro catches killers, and they say it takes a village to race one.
耳垫专为舒适度而设计，并提供多种颜色和表面处理。Dyson On Track。耳机重制版。请在DysonCanada.ca购买。开启主动降噪（ANC）时，性能可能会因环境条件和使用情况而异。配件单独出售。开启主动降噪（ANC）时，性能可能会因环境条件和使用情况而异，配件单独出售。迈阿密警局抓捕杀手，他们说抚养一个孩子需要一个村庄的力量。
Anyone knows how powerful urges can be? It's me. Catch Dexter Morgan in a new serial killer origin story. Hunger inside of you. It needs a master. Featuring Patrick Gibson, Christian Slater, special guest star Sarah Michelle Geller, with Patrick Dempsey and Michael C. Hall as Dexter's inner voice. I wasn't born a killer.
没有人比我更清楚冲动会有多强大。请在全新的连环杀手起源故事中关注德克斯特·摩根。你心中的饥饿。它需要一个主人。由帕特里克·吉布森、克里斯蒂安·史莱特主演，特别嘉宾明星莎拉·米歇尔·盖勒，还有帕特里克·登普西和迈克尔·C·霍尔饰演德克斯特的内心独白。我生来不是杀手。
I was made. Dexter Original Sin, new series now streaming exclusively on Paramount Plus, a mountain of entertainment. McDonald's has the gift that keeps giving. To Peter, your dog sitter, and Claire, who shovels your stairs. And to you, when you spend $25 on McDonald's gift cards in restaurants, get a coupon for a free Big Mac or McChicken. See details at participating McDonald's restaurants. Faith, as St. Augustine said, is a voluntary thing and not a matter of coercion.
我是被塑造出来的。《德克斯特：原罪》，全新剧集现正独家在派拉蒙+流媒体平台上线，这里有如山的娱乐内容。麦当劳提供源源不断的礼物。送给彼得，你的宠物保姆，还有克莱尔，她负责铲你家台阶上的雪。当你消费25美元购买麦当劳礼品卡时，即可获得一张免费巨无霸或麦香鸡的优惠券。详情请参阅参与活动的麦当劳餐厅。正如圣奥古斯丁所说，信仰是一件自愿的事情，而不是强迫的事情。
A person can be drawn into faith, not forced into it. A person can be forced into baptism, but that person will not advance in faith unless he be an infant. Even after people have received the faith and baptism, their weaker minds should be offered instruction with gentleness. For as the apostle Paul said when he wrote to his followers among the Galatians, I have fed you not with meat, but with milk.' So that was a letter written in 796 to Cortier in Charlemagne's train at the time when he's absolutely smiting the Saxons. Tom, about four seconds before I was about to read that,
一个人可以被引导进入信仰，而不是被强迫进入。一个人可以被强迫接受洗礼，但除非他是婴儿，否则他在信仰上就不会有长进。即使人们已经接受了信仰和洗礼，也应该以温和的方式向他们这些较为软弱的心智提供教导。因为正如使徒保罗在写信给加拉太的追随者时所说：“我给你们吃的是奶，不是饭。”所以那是796年写给查理曼随从柯蒂尔的一封信，当时他正在猛烈打击萨克森人。汤姆，大约在我准备读那段话的四秒钟前，
you said, oh, please, can you read that in a Yorkshire accent? Explain to the listeners why you wanted to hear that. Well, partly because I always enjoy hearing your Yorkshire accent, but also because the author of that letter was from York. He was a Northumbrian, so an Anglo-Saxon called Alcwyn. And Alcwyn was a very distinguished scholar in the noblest traditions of the great achievements of Northumbrian scholarship. Generable bead. So he had been taught by a disciple of bead, exactly. So there's a kind of scholarly link
你说，哦，求求你，你能用约克郡口音读一下吗？向听众解释一下你为什么想听这个。嗯，部分原因是我总是喜欢听你的约克郡口音，但也是因为那封信的作者来自约克。他是一个诺森比亚人，也就是一个叫阿尔昆的盎格鲁-萨克森人。阿尔昆是诺森比亚学术伟大成就中最崇高传统的杰出学者。尊者比德。所以他是比德的门徒教出来的，完全正确。所以有一种学术上的联系
between those two extraordinary people. And Einhard, again, the biography of Charlemagne, he thought Alcuin was brilliant. He described him as the most learned man to be found anywhere. Wow. And the thing that's impressive about Alcuin is that he's also very, very good at politics. He's kind of very seasoned diplomat. So in 781, he gets sent by the Bishop of York who basically wants to be an archbishop and there's some doubt about this. And so Alcuin goes to Rome to negotiate the absolute confirmation that the Bishop of York is actually an archbishop and Alcuin succeeds in doing that. And then he's going back through Italy when he runs into Charlemagne and Charlemagne is all over him and says, please come and
连接着这两个非凡的人。而艾因哈德，同样在查理曼传记中，他认为阿尔昆非常才华横溢。他将其描述为无处能及的最博学者。哇。而阿尔昆令人印象深刻的地方在于，他在政治上也非同寻常地出色。他算是一位经验丰富的外交官。所以在781年，他被约克主教派去，这位主教基本上想成为大主教，而对此存在一些疑虑。于是阿尔昆前往罗马，去谈判并绝对确认约克主教实际上就是一位大主教，而阿尔昆成功做到了这一点。然后他在返回意大利的途中遇到了查理曼，查理曼对他赞赏有加，并说，请来
stay with me, stay in my court. And the reason for that is that Charlemagne, as well as being a very successful and on occasion brutal warlord, is also a man who is devoted to learning, to scholarship, to broadening the cultural horizons of himself and of his people. Essentially, he wants a teacher and Alcuin is a brilliant teacher. He stays at Charlemagne's side. He goes back to England for a couple of years, but otherwise he stays in Francia from this point onwards. And from his letters, you can see he's a bit scared of Charlemagne. He's a bit nervous of him, but they do seem to have become genuinely good friends. So Charlemagne has this massive bath complex and they hang out in the baths together,
和我一起住，留在我的宫廷里。原因在于，查理曼不仅是一位非常成功且偶尔残暴的军阀，也是一个致力于学习、学术以及拓宽自己和人民文化视野的人。本质上，他想要一个老师，而阿尔昆是一位出色的老师。他留在查理曼身边。他回英格兰呆了几年，但除此之外，从那时起他就一直呆在法兰克。从他的信件中，你可以看出他有点害怕查理曼。他对他有点紧张，但他们似乎确实成了真正的 好朋友。所以查理曼有这个巨大的浴场综合体，他们一起在浴场里闲逛，
kind of, you know, making jokes about Virgil. Alcuin's a great japester, he's a great one for a nickname. He calls Charlemagne, perhaps tellingly, David, as in King David. It's all great banter and they get on tremendously well. Alcuin is by Charlemagne's side pretty continuously throughout this period. Then in 796, he's quite elderly by this point, I think he's about 60, he retires to Tor, which of course is the great shrine of St. Martin. So it's the most significant of all the Frankish shrines. There he becomes the abbot, but he continues to take an interest obviously in what's going on beyond the walls of the monastery. In 796, which is the year that he's gone to Tor, there
某种程度上，你知道，拿维吉尔开玩笑。阿尔昆是个绝妙的爱开玩笑的人，他特别擅长起绰号。他称查理曼为大卫，或许意味深长地，就像大卫王一样。这全都是极好的玩笑，他们相处得极其融洽。在这一时期，阿尔昆几乎一直陪伴在查理曼身旁。然后到了796年，此时他已经相当老了，我想他大约60岁了，他隐退到了图尔，那里当然是圣马丁的伟大圣地。所以它是所有法兰克圣地中最重要的一处。在那里他成为了修道院院长，但他显然继续关注着修道院高墙之外发生的事情。在796年，也就是他前往图尔的那一年，
is one thing more than anything else that is worrying Alquin. And essentially it's Charlemagne's policy in the East, his policy to the Saxons. Right. And this is because he thinks Charlemagne's let himself down a bit by being so savage, by being so repressive, is it? Essentially yes. It's because what Charlemagne is doing is a very radical policy. It's not something that Christian kings and emperors have been in the habit of doing, kind of imposing conversion at the point of a sword. People may have a vague sense that this is all that medieval kings did, but certainly in the early Middle Ages and even back in the final years
有一件事比其他任何事情都更让阿尔昆担忧。本质上，这就是查理曼在东方的政策，他对萨克森人的政策。没错。这是因为他认为查理曼由于如此野蛮、如此压制而有点让自己失望了，是这样吗？本质上是的。这是因为查理曼正在做的是一项非常激进的政策。这不是基督教国王和皇帝们习惯做的事情，也就是刀尖逼迫下的强加改宗。人们可能有一种模糊的意识，认为这正是中世纪国王所做的一切，但绝对在早中世纪，甚至在基督教皇帝的最后几年里，
of the Christian emperor, this wasn't what was happening. Because the Roman assumption, which the Franks seem to have inherited, is basically that to have faith in Christ is both a kind of a marker and a perk of being civilized. And the Christian God is so powerful, why would you want to share him with your enemies? I mean, it's much better to keep him for yourself. But I think that the longer that Charlemagne fights the Saxons, the more obdurate the Saxons seem to be, the more he comes to think that his enemies are fighting in the shadow of demons, that he is making war not just against the Saxons themselves, but against these monstrous demons
事情并不是这样的。因为罗马人的假设（法兰克人似乎继承了这一假设）基本上是，对基督有信仰既是文明的一种标志，也是一种特权。而且基督教的上帝是如此强大，你为什么会想和你的敌人分享他呢？我的意思是，把他留给自己要好得多。但我认为，查理曼与萨克森人战斗的时间越长，萨克森人似乎就越顽固，他就越认为他的敌人是在恶魔的阴影下战斗，他不仅是在与萨克森人本身作战，而且是在与这些他所崇拜的骇人恶魔作战。因此，你知道，除非他把这些可怕且邪恶的神灵从他们的土地上驱逐出去，否则他永远不会击败萨克森人。因此，除了军事战略外，他还强加了这样一种战略，基本上是以极端的偏见彻底消灭异教。因此，在776年，查理曼对萨克森人强加了一项条约，迫使他们接受洗礼。他们没有任何选择，在利珀河畔有这样一种集体洗礼，成千上万的人接受了洗礼。但当然，他一走，他们就全都故态复萌了。这随后似乎成了叛教，查理曼愈发愤怒。于是这变成了一种可怕的循环。在785年，他宣布
that they worship. And that therefore, you know, he will never defeat the Saxons until he has also banished these terrifying and demonic gods from their lands. So in addition to his military strategy, he imposes this strategy essentially of trying to wipe paganism out with extreme prejudice. So in 776, Charlemagne imposes a treaty on the Saxons that obliges them to accept baptism. They don't have any choice and there's this kind of mass baptism in the River Lippe, kind of thousands and thousands are baptized. But then of course, the moment he's gone, they all revert. And this then seems apostasy and Charlemagne is made even more furious. And so it becomes a kind of hideous cycle. In 785, he pronounces that
鄙视接受洗礼，即拒绝洗礼的提议，此后将罪该当死。他还列举了其他一大堆长期以来一直是萨克森传统生活方式一部分的做法。这些同样是死罪，比如向恶魔献祭（正如查理曼所描述的那样）、火葬。你不被允许这样做。你必须掩埋尸体，或者在大斋期（复活节前的四十天）吃肉。这是任何人尝试过的、让一个民族皈依基督的最残暴的计划。这就是阿尔昆反对它的原因。他觉得这根本不是一个基督教国王应该做的事情。我认为，对阿尔昆来说，加剧这种感觉的是他是一个盎格鲁-萨克森人。
scorning to come to baptism, so refusing the offer of baptism will henceforward merit death. And he also lists a whole host of other practices that have been part of Saxon traditional way of life for goodness how long. These two are capital offenses, so offering sacrifice to demons, as Charlemagne describes it, cremation. You're not allowed to do that. You have to bury your body, or eating meat during Lent, so the 40 days before Easter. This is by miles the most brutal program for bringing a people to Christ that anyone has ever attempted. This is why Alcuin objects to it. He feels that this is not what a Christian king should be doing at all. I think what sharpens this sense for Alcuin is that he is an Anglo-Saxon.
盎格鲁-萨克森人记得他们是如何皈依的，这基本上是通过圣徒的榜样和启示，而不是战士。无论是北方将诺森比亚皈依的爱尔兰修士，还是在奥古斯丁带领下从罗马派出的传教士，他们在坎特伯雷建立了我大主教区。我想盎格鲁-萨克森人对萨克森人也有一种亲近感。有一种感觉，他们是表亲。当然，是的。所以在8世纪的进程中，这一直是许多盎格鲁-萨克森传教士前往异教德国的灵感来源。所以我们在上一集里谈到了其中一位，
The Anglo-Saxons remember how they had been converted, which is essentially by the example and the inspiration of holy men, not warriors. So whether it's Irish monks in the North who convert Northumbria or the missionaries sent from Rome under Augustine who founds the archbishop Rick in Canterbury. And I think the Anglo-Saxons also have a feeling of kinship with the Saxons. There's a sense that they're cousins. Of course, yeah. And so this had been an inspiration for a lot of Anglo-Saxon missionaries over the course of the eighth century to go to pagan Germany. So we talked about one of them in the previous
来自德文郡的卜尼法斯。卜尼法斯曾去过那里，他对异教绝对没有手软。就像查理曼一样，他曾面对过一棵对索尔神圣的大圣树，他把它砍倒并变成了一座教堂。但卜尼法斯的事情在于，他这样做时背后并没有披甲的士兵。他作为是一个不携带武器的人在做这件事。尽管卜尼法斯得到了查理·马特的资助，但他从未转向法兰克军阀说，你能给我一些人吗？关键在于，如果你面对的是武装战士，那么你就让他们把你砍倒。
episode, Boniface from Devon. And Boniface had gone out there and he'd certainly given no quarter to paganism. So like Charlemagne, he had been confronted with a great holy tree that had been sacred to Thor and he'd chopped it down and turned it into a church. But the thing about Boniface is he does this without kind of mailed men at his back. He is doing it as someone who is not carrying weapons. And even though Boniface was sponsored by Charles Martel, he never turns to the Frankish warlord and says, can you give me some men? The whole point is that if you are confronted by armed warriors, then you allow them to cut you down.
而这正是卜尼法斯实际的遭遇。因此，在754年，他被弗里斯兰海盗砍死。他手里拿着的、为了试图挡住刀剑的致命一击而举起的祈祷书，被一路砍穿，并作为圣物被保存了下来。这是基督徒如何正确让异教徒皈依的榜样。你不应该闯进去，你知道，大开杀戒、烧毁村庄之类的事情。这就是阿尔昆的感受。所以当阿尔昆看着这一切时，他告诉了查理曼，不是吗？他有一个正在被喂奶的婴儿的意象。
And this is what actually happens to Boniface. So in 754, he's hacked to death by Frisian pirates. The prayer book that he had in his hand in which he held up to try and stop the blow of the sword gets cuts all the way through it and is preserved as a holy relic. And it's an example to Christians of how you should properly convert pagans. You shouldn't be going in and, you know, massacring them, burning villages and things. This is Alcuin's feeling. So when Alcuin, he looks at this, he tells Charmaine, doesn't he? He has this image of an infant being given milk.
是的，他很喜欢这个。让刚皈依基督的人像婴儿被喂奶一样，以温和的方式得到滋养。如果你残忍地教导他们，那么由于他们心智软弱，风险在于他们会把所有东西都吐出来。我的意思是，对这个如此权势滔天的人写下这样的话，基本上说你的整个政策是误入歧途的，而且实际上适得其反，因为他们会把你们强行塞进他们喉咙里的信仰吐出来，这真是相当大胆。是的。当然，言下之意也是你这样做违背了上帝的意旨。我同意，阿尔昆这样做很勇敢。我的意思是，他们可能会在浴场里闲逛并开玩笑，但查理曼仍然是一个非常令人生畏的人物。但阿尔昆确实
Yeah, he loves that. Let people's newly brought to Christ be nourished in a mild manner as infants are given milk. If you instruct them brutally, the risk then, their minds being weak, is they will vomit everything up. I mean, that's a pretty bold thing to write to this guy who's so powerful, to basically say your entire policy is misguided and is actually counterproductive because they will vomit back up the faith that you're forcing down their throats. Yeah. And of course, unspoken is also the thought that you are going against God's will in doing this. And I agree, it is brave of Alcuin to do it. I mean, they may hang out in the baths and banter, but Charlemagne is still a very intimidating figure. But Alcuin does
写信给他了。而令人惊奇的是，查理曼似乎欣然接受了这一点。同年，即796年，他下令放宽强制洗礼计划。然后第二年，他为萨克森人颁布了一项新宪章，放宽了那些法令。我不会说让反异教法变得更自由。那样说未免有些时代错误，但我想是让它们不那么具有惩罚性了。因此，阿尔昆的看法是，本质上你应该依靠修道院而不是某种军事堡垒来平定萨克森人。查理曼没有走那么远。他继续骚扰、焚烧等等。但我认为在某种意义上，那些建在萨克森人后方、查理曼开始将其布满王国东部边缘的修道院，曾被学者们比作伟大的罗马军团基地。这些是
write to him. And what's amazing is that Charlemagne seems to have taken it on the chin. That same year, 796, he orders the program of forcible baptisms to be eased. Then the following year, he issues a new charter for the Saxons, easing off the prescriptions. I wouldn't say making the laws against paganism more liberal. That would be an anachronistic way of putting it, but making them slightly less punitive, I guess. So Alcuin's take is that essentially you should rely on monasteries rather than on kind of military forts to pacify the Saxons. Charlemagne doesn't go that far. He continues to Harry and Bern and whatever. But I think there is a sense in which the monasteries that are built in the kind of the rear of the Saxons and which Charlemagne starts to plant over the eastern reaches of his kingdom, they have been compared by scholars to the great Roman legionary bases. These are centres
基督教力量的中心，基督教可以从这里向外辐射并向东传播。从这个意义上说，它完美地融合了correctio的双重含义，这个拉丁词汇意指在无序的地方带来秩序，即这既是手持长剑的战士的事，也是手握笔杆的学者和修士的事。所以有这样一个短语，加洛林文艺复兴。加洛林人并不认为他们在做的事是一场文艺复兴，因为他们认为他们所做的事仅仅是延续追溯至基督教罗马帝国的传统，只是有些事情需要被纠正。所以这就是该计划的全部意义所在。
of Christian power from which Christianity can reach outwards and spread eastwards. And in that sense, it kind of perfectly fuses the double meaning of correctio, this Latin word for bringing order where there's disorder, that it is a matter both for warriors with swords and for scholars and monks with pens. So there's this phrase, the Carolingian Renaissance. The Carolingians don't think that what they're doing is a Renaissance because they think that what they're doing is simply carrying on traditions that reach back to the Christian Roman Empire, but that things need to be corrected. And so that's what the programme is all about.
这不是一场文艺复兴，这是一个correctio（纠正）计划。没错。而且不仅仅是在萨克森人中间。查理曼也相信他自己的人民值得……这里用“纠正”这个词合适吗？我认为是的。好吧。有这样一句台词，应当为提升知识这项任务挑选那些有意志力和学习能力、以及指导他人愿望的人。
It's not a Renaissance, it's a programme of correctio. Right. And not just among the Saxons. Charlemagne also believes that his own people worthy of… is correction the right word here? I think it is. Okay. There's this line, let men be chosen for the task of improving knowledge who have the will and ability to learn and also the desire to instruct others.
所以基本上这是在他自己的人民中间开展的一个庞大的教育学教育计划。还有他自己，这就是为什么他找了阿尔昆，你知道，他想要一位伟大的老师呆在他身边。我认为其中的原因，有点像，听众可能还记得不久前，我们做过一集关于阿尔弗雷德的节目。在阿尔弗雷德战胜维京人后，他的首要目标是恢复修道院，因为他将学习视为带领他的人民上天堂、赢得永生的根本。作为国王，那是他的职责。如果他不这样做，如果他没有成功地将他管辖下的灵魂带到基督面前，那么他将在
So basically it's a huge pedagogical educational program among his own people. And himself, which is why he had got Alcuin, you know, he wanted a great teacher by his side. And I think the reason for this, it's a bit like, listeners may remember a while ago, we did an episode on Alfred. After Alfred's victories over the Vikings, his first aim is to restore the monasteries because he sees learning as fundamental to bringing his people to heaven, to winning them eternal life. And that is his duty as king. If he doesn't do that, if he doesn't succeed in bringing the souls under his charge to Christ, then he will answer
审判日为此负责。我想同样的阴影也笼罩在查理曼心头。对他是说这是一个非常紧急、迫切的使命。所以这有点像教育、教育、教育，但它不仅仅是为了教育而教育。这是为了把他的子民带上天堂。这就是为什么我认为他如此热衷于阿尔昆，因为他从他的父亲丕平和祖父查理·马特那里继承了一种观念，即盎格鲁-萨克森人实际上最擅长这种事情。所以卜尼法斯在去异教徒中传教时，实际上也不得不在法兰克帝国东翼的人民中间做很多艰苦的工作，这些人本应几个世纪以来都是基督徒，因为他发现他们处于一种可怕的状态。所以他写道
for it at the day of judgment. And I think the same shadow hangs over Charlemagne. It's a really urgent, pressing mission for him. So it is kind of education, education, education, but it's not just education for its own sake. It's about getting his people to heaven. And that's why I think he's so keen on Alcuin, because he has inherited from his father Pepin and his grandfather, Charles Martel, a sense that actually the Anglo-Saxons are best at this kind of thing. So Boniface, when he had gone out to convert the pagans, he'd actually also had to work quite hard among the people on the Eastern flank of the Frankish Empire, who supposedly been Christian for centuries, because he finds that they're in a terrible state. So he writes
关于法兰克神职人员，他们把一生都花在荒淫、通奸和各种污秽之中。他写下这些并不是出于任何嫉妒的语气。他确实感到非常非常震惊。平心而论，几个世纪以来，有那么多英国作家对法国人都是这么说的，不是吗？这或许是第一个例子。关于来到法兰克（也就是高卢，一个本应人们说拉丁语的罗马行省）的盎格鲁-萨克森学者，还有一件非常引人注目的事。盎格鲁-萨克森学者是从书本中学习拉丁语的。他们到达高卢后，发现法兰克人说的拉丁语基本上令人费解。而
of the Frankish clergy, they spend their lives in debauchery, adultery, and every kind of filth. And he's not writing that in any tone of jealousy. He's genuinely very, very appalled by this. To be fair, it's what so many English writers down the centuries have said about the French, isn't it? That's the first example, perhaps. And the other thing also that's very striking about Anglo-Saxon scholars when they come to Francia, which was Gaul, a Roman province where people supposedly speak Latin. The Anglo-Saxon scholars have learned their Latin from books. They arrive in Gaul and they find the Latin being spoken by the Franks basically unintelligible. And
原因在于，它正处于变成法语的边缘。你知道，它在演变。但对阿尔昆和他的伙伴们来说，这表明法兰克人无可救药地缺乏教育，他们让从罗马人那里继承的遗产溜走了，因此，不仅他们的道德需要改进，他们说拉丁语的能力也需要改进。这很重要，因为对于那些被罗马传教士劝导皈依的盎格鲁-萨克森人来说，基督教与“罗马性”之间的联系比法兰克人更强。所以我们之前讨论过这一点。对法兰克人来说，基督教一直是高卢式的。它在高卢内部一直是自给自足的。它没有向罗马寻求榜样。但对盎格鲁-萨克森人来说，
the reason for that is that it's on the verge of becoming French. You know, it's evolving. But to Alcuin and his compadres, it's a sign that the Franks are hopelessly uneducated, that they've let their inheritance from the Romans slip and that therefore, it's not just their morals that need improving, it's also their ability to speak Latin. And that matters because to the Anglo-Saxons who had been converted by Roman missionaries, the association between Christianity and Romanitas is much stronger than it is among the Franks. So we talked about this before. For the Franks, Christianity had always been Gallic. It had always been self-sufficient within Gaul. It hadn't looked to Rome for its example. But for the Anglo-Saxons,
罗马是伟大的榜样。是教皇让他们皈依的。因此，身为阿尔昆这样的盎格鲁-萨克森人掌管着法兰克最重要的修道院这一事实，对于将法兰克人的基督教观念融入一种全欧洲范围的理解并使其罗马化，真的非常重要。所以正是从这个时候起，你才真正开始拥有某种共同的拉丁基督教，而不是那种由多种不同版本组成的基督教。没错。
Rome is the great example. It's a pope who converted them. And so the fact that it's an Anglo-Saxon like Alcuin who is in charge of the most significant monastery in Francia is really important in integrating Frankish notions of Christianity into a kind of Europe-wide understanding and making it Roman. So it's from this point onwards that you really start to have a kind of common Latin Christianity rather than one that is a Christianity that consists of multiple different versions of it. Right.
你知道，罗马一个，高卢一个，无论哪儿都有一个。而这个过程的巨大动力就是阿尔昆在图尔的修道院，对吧？所以图尔，显然有圣马丁，我们听过很多关于圣马丁的事，听过他对于法兰克人有多么重要。所以这确实是学术的一个枢纽。他们正在抄写所有这些古典文本以试图提高拉丁语的标准，并且他们正在制作所有这些经文集，不是吗？所以第一批，实际上，这些是第一批圣经。是这样吗？向那些可能对此外感到迷惑的人解释，这些
You know, one in Rome, one in Gaul, one in wherever. And the great powerhouse of this process is Alcuin's monastery in Tours, isn't it? So Tours, obviously, St. Martin, we've heard loads about St. Martin, how important he was for the Franks. So this is a real sort of hub of scholarship. They're copying out all these classical texts to try and improve the standards of Latin, and they're producing all these collections of scripture, aren't they? So the first, actually, these are the first Bibles. Is that right? Explain to people who may be baffled by that how these
怎么可能是第一批圣经呢？所以“圣经”这个词来自希腊语“bliad”，意思是书籍，而基督教经文包含许多不同的书。此前并没有将它们收集在单一文本中的习惯。但阿尔昆对此非常热心。有这样做的传统，比如说在诺森比亚的修道院里，他把这个带到了图尔。正是从这个时候起，这些被汇集在封面内、装订成单一书册的经文集，开始被统称为Biblia，也就是圣经。所以正是从这个时候开始，你才开始有了圣经。而阿尔昆的
could possibly be the first Bibles. So the word Bible comes from the Greek word bliad, which means books, and Christian scriptures consist of lots of different books. And it had not previously been the habit to gather them within a single text. But Alcuin is all over this. There is a tradition of doing this, say, in the Northumbrian monasteries, and he brings this to tour. And it's from this point on, really, that these collections of books which are being assembled within the covers, within a single set of covers, start to be known collectively as Biblia, i.e. a Bible. So it's from this point on that you start to get Bibles. And Alcuin's
目标是尽可能多地印行这些圣经。这其实相当具有信息技术的感觉。图尔有一个修士。他拿起一本这样的圣经，惊讶地发现你可以在单一文本中找到旧约和新约的所有不同书卷。他惊叹道，这是一座无与伦比的图书馆。这有点像iPhone或iPad或其他什么刚问世时，人们会说，全世界的知识都在这个小小的平板电脑上、这个小小手机上。阿尔昆相当于是史蒂夫·乔布斯，因为他非常强调的不仅是数据量，而且这些数据、这些书应该易于使用、易于阅读、它们应该是美丽的、制作质量应该
aim is to get as many of these Bibles out as he possibly can. And it's actually quite kind of information technology. There's a monk in Tor. He picks up one of these Bibles and he's amazed that you get all the different books of the Old Testament and the New Testament in a single text. He exclaims, this is a library beyond compare. It's a bit like when iPhones or iPads or whatever first came out, that people would say, all the knowledge of the world is on this tiny little tablet, this tiny little phone. And Alcuin is quite Steve Jobs because he has a massive emphasis, not just on the volume of data, but also that this data, these books should be easy to use, easy to read, that they should be beautiful, that the production qualities should
完全精简。因此，在图尔的抄经室里制作的圣经以及其他书籍，都是为了尽可能做到对用户友好而编写的。本质上，当你现在看用罗马字母（也就是英语、法语、德语及其他语言使用的字母）书写的文本块时，你看到的是经过加洛林学者、阿尔昆和他的同仁修士们调解过的字体。所以正是在阿尔昆的指导下，单词第一次不再连写在一起。因此，如果你想想罗马碑文，你知道，没有空格，但现在你开始有了空格。此外，还使用大写字母来表示新句子。同样，这是一项彻底的创新。而我最喜欢的创新，加洛林人开始引入新句子。同样，这是一项彻底的创新。而我最喜欢的创新，
be completely streamlined. And so the Bibles and other books as well that are being produced in the scriptorium at Taw are written to be as user-friendly as possible. And essentially, when you look at a block of text now written in the Roman script, so the script that English and French and German and everything uses, you are looking at a script that has been mediated by Carolingian scholars, by Alcuin and his fellow monks. So it's under Alcuin's guidance that for the first time, words don't run into one another. So if you think of a Roman inscription, you know, there's no spaces, but now you start to get spaces. Also the use of capitals to indicate new sentences. Again, a complete innovation. And my favourite innovation, the Carolingian start to introduce new sentences. Again, a complete innovation. And my favorite innovation, the
加洛林人开始引入新的标点符号。在表达怀疑的句子中，他们开始使用一种闪电符号，随着时间的推移，它将演变成问号。哇。这太棒了。所以，阿尔昆，你知道，他满脑子都是教义之乳之类的东西，但他也是圣经和问号的发明者。我从没想过问号居然是句号上面加一道闪电，但那当然也就是它的原型。一个稍微有些摇晃的闪电符号。
Carolingian start to introduce new punctuation marks. And in a sentence where there is doubt being expressed, they start to use a kind of lightning flash, which over the course of time will evolve to become the question mark. Wow. It's brilliant. So again, Alquin, you know, he's all about the milk of doctrine and all that, but he also he's the inventor of the Bible and the question mark. I'd never thought of a question mark as a lightning bolt over a full stop, but that's of course is kind of what it is. A slightly wobbly lightning bolt.
是的。所以是对句号提出质疑。完全正确。所以他们基本上在大批量印制这些圣经，它们具有可读性、采用非常美观且对用户友好的排版格式，并且它们大概是统一的工具，对吧？完全正确。贯穿查理曼的帝国。这正是他所追求的。是的，他在创造一种共同的基督教文化。当然，文本是给识字的人准备的，所以这些圣经大概会流向
Yes. So questioning the full stop. Exactly. So they're basically pumping these out, all these Bibles, they're readable, they're in a very beautiful, user-friendly kind of format, and they are presumably a tool of uniformity, right? Exactly. Across Charlemagne's empire. That's what he's after. Yes, he's creating a common Christian culture. And of course, texts are for those who can read, so these Bibles are kind of going to
修道院或其他地方。但查理曼和阿尔昆都非常非常渴望深入乡村。所以人们可能会纳惑，自克洛维皈依以来已经过去很长时间了。法兰克精英、贵族阶层等等显然都非常非常虔诚，但乡村里的农民呢？他们对这些了解多少？可能少之又少。这些人也是查理曼非常关心的对象。而这里最关键的人物是教区神父。卜尼法斯曾抱怨过他们无可救药、什么都不懂的事实。而阿尔昆实际上也表示，他担心神父们其实并不知道
monasteries or whatever. But Charlemagne and Alcuin are both very, very concerned to reach out into the countryside. So people may wonder, it's a long time since Clovis was converted. The Frankish elites, the aristocracy, all of that are clearly very, very Christian, but what about the peasants out in the countryside? What do they know about it? Probably very little. And these are the people that Charlemagne is also very, very concerned to reach. And the key people here are the parish priests. And Boniface had complained about the fact that they're hopeless, they don't know anything. And Alcuin also actually says he worries that the priests, they don't really
他们在谈论什么。所以同样，他设计了一些小册子、小开本的书籍，可以塞进小袋子里之类的，里面提供了基督教教义的基础知识、主祷文、信经、圣经中的各种关键段落等等。这些被送到各个教区，送到乡村。这是西方历史上空前绝后的全民教育实验。在几十年内，法兰克的为主教们就能够假定神父应该具备最基本的知识水平。事实上，大约在840年代，有一个关于某位神父的精彩记述，他因为忘记了自己学过的一切而被主教监禁，这总是在我脑海里挥之不去。哇。我的意思是，如果你因为忘记了学过的一切而受到惩罚，
know what they're talking about. And so again, he devises kind of little books, little format books that can be slipped into a pouch or something that give the basics of Christian doctrine, give the Lord's Prayer, give the Creed, give various key passages from scripture or whatever. And these are sent out into the parishes, out into the countryside. And it's an unprecedented experiment in the West in mass education. And within a few decades, the bishops in Frankia are able to assume that priests should have a basic modicum of knowledge. And in fact, there's this wonderful account of a priest in about the kind of the eight 40s, who gets imprisoned by his bishop for having forgotten everything that he had learned, which always kind of sticks in my mind. Wow. I mean, if you got punished for forgetting everything you'd learned,
那可真是一个大问题。这同样让人难以强调这在西欧历史上是多么重大的一刻，因为这是基督教化进程真正开始发生的一刻。它不再仅仅属于精英阶层，它正在深入乡村。生活中最基本的节奏，无论是年度的还是从摇篮到坟墓的，都开始浸润在基督教中。所以，你知道，如果你在起草一份宪章、一份法律协议，如果你在照顾一头生病的动物，如果你在计算应该在哪里挖井、什么时候开始收割，所有这些问题都开始由那些被赋予了
that would be a real problem. And this again, it's hard to emphasize how significant a moment this is in the history of Western Europe, because this is the moment when the process of Christianisation really starts to happen. It's not just for the elites anymore, it's reaching out into the countryside. And the most basic rhythms of life, whether it's kind of annual or whether it's from cradle to grave, are starting to be marinated in Christianity. So, you know, if you're drawing up a charter, a legal agreement, if you're tending to a sick animal, if you're working out where you should dig a well, when you should begin the harvest, all of these questions are starting to be framed in Christian terms by priests who have been given
能够做到这一点的知识诀窍和弹药的神父们，用基督教的术语来构建。因为在每个村庄、每个城镇、每个小村落里，都会有一些教区神父或其他什么人，拿着他的小书站在那里，你知道，这是这个场合的祈祷文，这是耶稣会怎么做，巴拉巴拉巴拉巴拉，而在100或200年前，情况并非如此。是的。查理曼规定每个神父都应该知道主祷文和信经，并且他们反过来应该教导他王国里的每个人信经和主祷文。所以这赋予了人们一种
the kind of intellectual know-how and ammunition that enables them to do this. Because in every village, every town, every hamlet, there is going to be some parish priest or something who sits standing there with his little book, you know, this is the prayer for this occasion, this is what Jesus would do, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, in a way that wasn't the case 100 or 200 years before this. Yeah. And Charlemagne has prescribed that every priest should know the Lord's Prayer and should know the Creed, and that they should in turn instruct everybody in his kingdom in the Creed and in the Lord's Prayer. And so that is giving to people kind of fundamentals
对基督教的熟悉程度的基础，而这是他们以前所没有的。它产生了一种饱和效应。其结果对欧洲文化的未来具有极其深远的意义。这意味着人们开始把植根于基督教的假设视为理所当然，甚至没有意识到这些假设是从哪里来的。我想正是在这个意义上，你可以称查理曼为“欧洲之父”。所以这是在他有生之年就套用在他身上的一个短语。我的意思是，从方方面面来看，称他为这个是个荒谬的说法，因为正如我们将看到的，他的帝国实际上并没有持续多久。但我认为在这个意义上，即对
of familiarity with Christianity that they hadn't previously had. It has a kind of saturating effect. The consequences of that are utterly profound for the future of European culture. It means that people start to take for granted assumptions that are rooted in Christianity to the point where they don't even realise where these assumptions have come from. I think it's in this sense that you can call Charlemagne the father of Europe. So this is a phrase that is being applied to him within his own lifetime. I mean, in all kinds of ways, it's a ridiculous thing to call him because as we will see, his empire actually doesn't last very long. But I think in this one sense, the Christianisation of people
乡村偏远地区人民的基督教化上，他确实配得上这个称号。但当然，多米尼克，“欧洲之父”并不是他最终获得的唯一头衔。不，他得到了一个宏大得多的头衔。他确实得到了。所以，也许我们会在最后一集中探讨这个更宏大的头衔（他的帝国头衔）的故事。而且因为我们感觉到了节日的气氛，汤姆，我们将
out in the reaches of the countryside, he does deserve that title. But of course, Dominic, Father of Europe is not the only title that he will end up with. No, he ends up with a much grander title. He does. So, maybe we will explore the story of that grander title, his imperial title, in the final episode. And because we're feeling festive, Tom, we will
探讨那个故事。这个强大系列的最高潮，将在周四（如往常一样）发布，而是将在周三，即12月25日圣诞节发布。这其实背后有一个很好的历史原因，不是吗？我们将在下次节目中探讨这一点，因为如果你是“历史就是一切”俱乐部的会员，你显然可以立即收听，你随时可以在therestishistory.com加入该俱乐部。但收听那一集的最佳时机绝对会是圣诞节。根据我在你的笔记中读到的，这是整个欧洲历史上最具标志性的时刻之一。
explore that story. The climax of this mighty series, it will be out not on Thursday, as usual, but it'll be on Wednesday, Christmas day, the 25th of December. And there is actually a very good historical reason for that, isn't there? which we will explore next time, because obviously you could listen to it straight away if you're a member of the Rest is History Club, and you can always join that club at therestishistory.com. But the best time to listen to that episode is definitely going to be Christmas Day. It's one of the most, I read in your notes, one of the most iconic moments in the whole of European history.
场景是罗马，年份是公元800年，日期是圣诞节。所以请加入我们一起收听那一集。伴随着这枚重磅炸弹，再见。拜拜。大家好，我是多米尼克·桑德布鲁克。我是汤姆·霍兰德，我们有一些令人兴奋得难以置信的消息要告诉你们，对吧，多米尼克？
The scene is Rome, the year is AD 800, and the date is Christmas Day. So please join us for that. And on that bombshell, goodbye. Bye bye. ["Pomp and Circumstance"] Hello everybody, Dominic Sandbrook here. And I'm Tom Holland and we have some incredibly exciting news to tell you, don't we Dominic?
确实如此。所以我们经常说我们有令人兴奋的消息，但这绝对是极其令人兴奋的消息。我们非常高兴地宣布，继今年早些时候我们那场门票售罄的演出之后，“历史就是一切”将于5月4日星期日重返皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅，再次与管弦乐队同台现场演出。我们将为您带来一场全新的演出，这一次将讨论另外两位历史史上最非凡、迷人且最具标志性的古典音乐家，本案中是柴可夫斯基
We do. So we often say we've got exciting news, but this is genuinely very, very exciting news. We are thrilled to announce that after the sellout show that we did earlier this year, The Rest is History will be returning to the Royal Albert Hall on Sunday the 4th of May to perform live once again with an orchestra. And we will be bringing you a brand new show and this time discussing two more of history's most extraordinary, fascinating and iconic classical composers, in this case Tchaikovsky
和瓦格纳。这些非凡的人生将在著名指挥家奥利弗·泽费曼指挥的著名爱乐乐团的伴奏下被赋予生动活力。因此，我们今年做的第一场演出是一次真正光荣的经历，我们希望这也将是一个难忘的夜晚。会有美妙的音乐，我们会讲述精彩的故事，我们会深入历史。所以你最好尽快搞到这场演出的门票。这些门票将于12月19日星期四在www.royalalberthall.com上发售，“历史就是一切”俱乐部会员以及皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅的朋友和赞助商可以在24小时前提前预售，
and Wagner. And these extraordinary lives will be brought to life thanks to the accompaniment of the renowned Philharmonia Orchestra conducted by the celebrated Oliver Zefferman. So that first show that we did this year was a truly glorious experience and we are hoping that this too will be an unforgettable night. There'll be great music, we'll be telling great stories, we'll be delving into the history. So you had better get your hands on tickets for the show as soon as you can. And these tickets will be available from www.royalalberthall.com on Thursday the 19th of December with a pre-sale for the Rest is History Club members and Royal Albert Hall friends and patrons 24 hours earlier
即12月18日星期三上午10点。这就是“历史就是一切”携手爱乐乐团的现场演出，柴可夫斯基与瓦格纳。它将于5月4日星期日举行，地点在皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅。现在，门票对会员于12月18日星期三开放，对公众于12月19日星期四开放，请确保你不要错过它。你是“历史就是一切”的粉丝，但尚未潜入“历史就是一切”俱乐部这个奇妙而精彩的世界吗？或者你身边有什么亲近的人对这个节目赞不绝口？好吧，这里有一个提醒，我们在therestishistory.com提供礼品会员资格。
on Wednesday the 18th of December at 10am. That is The Rest is History live with the Philharmonia Orchestra, Tchaikovsky and Wagner. It's at the Royal Albert Hall on Sunday the 4th of May. Now the tickets are available for members on Wednesday the 18th of December and for the general public on Thursday the 19th of December and please make sure that you don't miss it. Are you a fan of The Rest is History but yet to dive into the weird and wonderful world of The Rest is History Club or is there someone dear to you who won't stop banging on about the show? Well, here is a reminder that we at therestishistory.com offer gift memberships.
所以，如果你擅长暗示，或者如果你缺少给家人、朋友或伴侣的礼物，我和汤姆想提醒你终极的圣诞袜塞礼物。这当然就是“历史就是一切”俱乐部的订阅服务，里面塞满了各种奖励剧集。它可以访问备受喜爱的Discord聊天社区，有新闻通讯，还有各种好东西。只需访问therestishistory.com并寻找礼品。如果你生命中的历史迷总是用关于
So if you're good at dropping hints or if you're short on a present for a family member, for a friend or for a partner, Tom and I would like to remind you of the ultimate Christmas stocking filler. And it is of course a subscription to the Rest is History Club, which is full to the brim with bonus episodes. It's got access to the much loved Discord chat community. It's got newsletters, it's got all kinds of goodies. Simply go to therestishistory.com and look for gifts. If the history buff in your life is always regaling you with the same old facts about
丘吉尔或拿破仑的那些陈词滥调来向你滔滔不绝，为什么不给他或她（咱们面对现实吧，就是给你自己）买一份礼物呢？毕竟，圣诞节即将来临，非常巧合的是，我们第一本官方的“历史就是一切”图书现已出版，作为完美的口袋大小平装书。它塞满了你从未想过要问的最离奇的历史问题，比如历史上最灾难性的派对是什么？哪个英国政客阴谋把他的情人喂给短吻鳄？为什么一个巴西皇帝会被误认为是一根香蕉？它肯定会让所有参与其中的人在节日期间变得更加有趣，并且现在它已经可以在各地书店买到了。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
Churchill or Napoleon, why not get him or her, and let's face it you, a present? After all, Christmas is just around the corner and a very happy coincidence, our first official Rest is History book is now out as the perfect stocking sized paperback. It is packed to the brim with the most bizarre historical questions you never thought to ask like what was the most disastrous party in history? Which British politician plotted to feed his lover to an alligator? And why was a Brazilian emperor mistaken for a banana? It's sure to make the festive period much more entertaining for all involved, and it is available in bookshops everywhere now. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
丘吉尔还是拿破仑，为什么不给他或她，还有我们面对现实吧，给你自己买一份礼物呢？毕竟，圣诞节就在转角，非常凑巧的是，我们首本官方版《历史静思录》现在已经推出了完美口袋书大小平装本。里面塞满了你从未想过要问的最离奇的历史问题，比如历史上最灾难性的派对是什么？哪个英国政客密谋把他的情人喂给短吻鳄？为什么一个巴西皇帝被误认为是一根香蕉？它肯定会让所有相关人员的节日更加有趣，现在各大书店均有售。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。